Bruselas aprobó El noveno paquete de
sanciones contra Rusia por la guerra en
Ucrania estamos muy contentos de
anunciarles que hemos logrado concluir
un acuerdo sobre el noveno paquete de
sanciones
eso demuestra que una vez más estamos
encontrando la manera de condenar
firmemente a Rusia por sus acciones en
Ucrania
aún no se conocen detalle el acuerdo
contra Moscú pero funcionarios de la ue
adelantaron que 200 rusos más entrarán
en la lista negra incluyendo empresarios
oficiales militares y funcionarios esto
implica el congelamiento de activos y la
prohibición de viajar en la Unión
Europea a su vez la industria minera
rusa sería el blanco de las sanciones y
se espera que el bloque comunitario
también prohíba la venta de motores de
aviones no tripulados tanto a Rusia como
Irán una táctica clave en la guerra ya
que Moscú ha empleado numerosos ataques
con drones de fabricación iraní sobre
territorio ucraniano Polonia y lituania
fueron enérgicos en endurecer las
sanciones en de ciclo advirtieron que
las excepciones a la exportación de
fertilizantes rusos con el fin de
garantizar la seguridad alimentaria
beneficiaban a los oligarcas rusos la v
también anunció más ayuda económica
Ucrania y reiteró su apoyo al presidente
bolodimir selensky
los estados de la Unión Europea se han
mantenido del lado ucraniano desde el
principio
Ucrania cuenta con nuestro apoyo
inquebrantable en la defensa de su
soberanía y la integridad de su
territorio
18 mil millones de euros serán
destinados en 2023 para financiar a
Ucrania en la guerra